how much money do you think actors
should invest in themselves every year
whether it be headshots and not counting
sag dues every new things like that but
just headshots you know IMDB Pro things
like that casting director workshops to
be safe I would say a good five to six
hundred dollars coconut maybe a little
bit more for some really good headshots
they're gonna be at least $200 you know
probably for one look demo reel that's
going to be some hundreds
I am DB Pro that's a good one fifty I
think per year
actors access is sixty eight dollars per
year la casting is about a hundred and
fifty or so dollars per year you have to
constantly print out headshots constant
that could be about a hundred dollars
for good quality resumes you have to
print those out on a by tuned you know
paper so you have to invest in that as
well
business cards are always essential you
know like I said the postcards don't
really work but business cards are
definitely good for when you're out and
about at mixers and networking events
you can always just past your past your
um your business cards out to someone
and actually have a little secret that I
shouldn't share but I do want to share
this my business card is pretty cool my
business card is actually inside of a
like a little cover with the mini disc
with my reel on it so I have just a
little little tiny little business card
media disc with my reel and with my
headshot on it and resume and everything
so when I give my business card out it's
a tiny little disc with my grill on it
so it's you know that's a good maybe
fifty bucks right there for those stacks
of discs but it works it works so
definitely five to six hundred dollars
per year
you